[Musik]
ich hatte kunden die mir gesagt haben
aber das schöne florenz sie dachten sie
seien in florenz natürlich muss man
einfach ja sagen denn man darf sie nicht
beleidigen von allen schädlichen tieren
ist der tour ist das schädlich
die stadt der kunst ist nichts anderes
als ein museum voller fremder die ihre
eigenen gewohnheiten verlegt haben
stendhal 1820
wenn wir dem inter das nagelbett dem
chinesen die essstäbchen unter dem
japaner eine badewanne hinstellen müssen
und sie essen keine polenta mit mir das
auto dann sollen sie doch lieber zu
hause bleiben wenn sie hierher kommen
werde ich ihnen polenta und beratung
anbieten
wir wissen dass die tatsache dass wir
allen gesagt haben das eine folge des
klimawandels das aussterben der eisbären
ist zu einem 3 100 prozentigen anstieg
der flüge geführt hat um die eisbären zu
sehen bevor sie verschwinden
im jahr 2016 gab es weltweit eine
milliarde 235 millionen touristen in
weniger als zehn jahren im jahr 2030
werden es nach unseren schätzungen eine
milliarde und 800 millionen sein
all diese menschen sind auf der ganzen
welt auf der suche nach entspannung mit
sehenswürdigkeiten nach orten die sie
unbedingt besuchen müssen alle zusammen
alle zur gleichen zeit
und wie bei allem anderen ist das zuviel
das problem vor allem an einigen der
angesagten reiseziele oder das phänomen
wird over to reason genannt und
verändert das aussehen und die
wirtschaftliche ordnung vieler städter
die überfüllten vaporetti wie sie sehen
können die armen kerle versuchen ihre
arbeit inmitten dieses verkehrs zu
erledigen überall taxis bis 12 uhr
mittags können wir mit unseren boten
nicht auf dem canale grande fahren er
ist für den tourismus in der stadt
reserviert also taxi gefragt und so
weiter
venedig hat jetzt die gleiche
luftqualität wie mailand und wir leben
in einer fußgänger stadt in der wir alle
nachteile haben wenn wir schwere taschen
zu fuß tragen müssen
wir haben die luftverschmutzung von
städten in denen die menschen mit autos
unterwegs sind hier ist alles diesel
vaporetti taxis transport boote sie alle
haben dieselmotoren schauen sie sich den
verkehr hier an und es ist nicht mal
rush hour
wir verkaufen die stadt zum wohle des
tourismus nicht wie zu zeiten der
venezianischen kurtisanen die wussten
wie man dinge organisiert nein es ist zu
einer regelrechten massen prostitution
geworden
das sind die bedingungen unter denen die
gondoliere heute arbeiten stellen sich
die stille vor als canaletto den canale
grande mato
dieser akustische verschmutzung die sie
unter der brücke hören
marco gasparini ist anwalt und hat die
gruppe fünfundzwanzigster april
gegründeten ein symbolischer namen das
datum der italienischen befreien um
dafür zu kämpfen dass venedig nicht vom
tourismus erstickt wird so soll zum
beispiel den bau und der umwandlung von
häusern in hotels ein ende gesetzt
werden vor allem wenn dies von einer
öffentlichen einrichtung durchgeführt
wird
das gericht hat seinen sitz in diesem
wunderschönen weißen palast dem palazzo
der kernenergie aber dieses ganze gebiet
ist jetzt von spekulation bedrohen wenn
man die kulissen anguckt kann man sich
vorstellen welche art von appetit
geweckt wird
im moment ist hier das berufungsgericht
untergebracht das bestimmt bald von der
eigentümerin der stadt venedig verkauft
wird um es in ein weiteres hotel
umzuwandeln auch das angrenzende gebäude
wird mit sicherheit verkauft nach einem
von uns organisierten grossaufmarsch mit
mehr als 2000 leuten auf der riba des
kia boni im vergangenen jahr hatte der
bürgermeister versprochen keine weiteren
hotels in venedig zu bauen genug wir
haben schon zu viele
also sagt er okay wir bauen sie
aufzudecken morano in mestre wo sie den
tourismus auf das ganze stadtgebiet
verteilen müssen sondern wir bessere
werden gerade tausende von mein hotel
unterkünften gebaut und jetzt sagt der
bürgermeister
aber nach besten geht man am besten zu
sehen
oder noch schlimmer wir können uns auch
um die touristen kümmern die nach jesolo
fahren jesu ist 40 kilometer von unserem
hotel entfernt ich stelle mir vor wie
die touristen in flipflops unter der
august sonne im gänsemarsch von mestre
nach jesolo marschieren machen ganz
nichts vor ich glaube dass der
bürgermeister die intelligenz der
venezianer unterschätzt doch was wenn in
mestre neue hotels gebaut werden dann
nicht für die touristen die nach jesolo
wollen sondern weil die touristen
venedig sehen wollen
in barcelona gibt es eine ähnliche
situation wo es regelmäßig graffiti
gegen touristen gibt
auch hier gibt es gruppen die das
phänomen bekämpfen
nicht alle mit den gleichen methoden
wir passen sehr auf die touristen nicht
anzugreifen denn sie trifft ja keine
schuld
es ist klar dass sich die leute nicht in
die touristen hineinfühlen
denn sie sind ja das hauptmerkmal sie
sind das was wir sehen wenn wir diese
verschlechterung unseres eigenen
lebensstils wahrnehmen
die frage die man sich stellen sollte
lautet warum sind sie alle hier oder
warum alle in venedig
es gibt eine spektakuläre konzentration
an bestimmten touristenorten auf der
ganzen welt und das ist kein zufall
es ist nicht so dass die touristen
zufällig kommen sie kommen weil es eine
propagandamaschine für den tourismus
gibt die jedem einbläut dass barcelona
der ort ist zu dem man gehen muss
und wenn man es nicht tut dann ist man
eben nichts
es ist nicht immer eine marketingaktion
die touristen anlocken ließen letztes
jahr genügte ein video auf youtube um
einen außergewöhnlichen zustrom von
menschen ins wäre das fatal auszulösen
weil er wird saskia das als die
malediven von mailand bekannt wurde
das malediven video letztes jahr war
eine gute sache alle hatten viel arbeit
die restaurants die geschäfte alle
es gab saubere leute die sich um ihren
müll gekümmert haben und andere die bier
und coca cola dosen weggeworfen haben
das war weniger gut für erdgas k s war
entwürdigend
ja ich habe letztes jahr auch gearbeitet
und mir ist aufgefallen dass nachdem das
video über die malediven von mailand
heraus kam es einen boom von
italienischen touristen gab es war eine
radikale veränderung denn die menschen
die dort schwimmen waren immer ganz
korrekt mit dem was sie dort
zurücklassen
der ansturm auf einen so kleinen bereich
des tals löste unmut und heftige kritik
aus
inzwischen haben sich die dinge geändert
die bewohner wollen nicht interviewt
werden um keine unruhe zu stiften und
die gemeinden des tals haben parkplätze
organisiert
mehr mülleimer
und chemische toiletten um den
restaurants zu helfen von denen einige
geschlossen hatten aus protest gegen die
menschenmasse die dort neu ihre notdurft
verrichten
ganz zu schweigen von der größten
herausforderung der
vermeidung von unfällen und
das ist nicht immer einfach
manche hören zu anderen ist es egal was
können wir denn schon tun wir warnen sie
wir haben präventivmaßnahmen aber wenn
keiner zuhört dann kann alles mögliche
passieren so ist das nun
und oft geschieht es direkt vor unseren
augen
eine frau die zu weit in die strömung
geraten war wurde von ihren freunden
unbeholfen gerettet
bevor die offiziellen retter kamen
konnte sie sich in sicherheit und das
mit einem ziemlichen schrecken
vielleicht war ihr gar nicht bewusst
dass sie gerade ihr leben riskiert hatte
wir haben viele mädchen die herumgehen
und helfen um probleme zu vermeiden
sie verteilen karten auf denen steht
worauf man achten muss wir müssen ihnen
ihr sagen passt auf wenn ihr in die
strömung geht das ist gefährlich
es kommt oft vor dass die leute im
urlaub besonders im ausland risiken
eingehen
ja meint iris cruisen oder unhöflich
sind
da war eine gruppe von deutschschweizern
die wollten in einer gefährlichen zone
tauchen oben in aquino und ich bin
dazwischen gegangen und habe ihnen
gesagt dass sie nicht tauchen sollen
wir haben herumgealbert und als sie im
wasser waren haben sie um hilfe gerufen
nur um sich über unsere arbeit lustig zu
machen
[Musik]
steigende touristenzahlen bedeuten
leider auch mehr schlechtes benehmen
ich glaube unhöflichkeit gab es schon
immer
die zunahme des massentourismus macht
das nur noch deutlicher nicht nur im
tourismus sondern generell
ein mensch in sakko und krawatte verhält
sich völlig anders als ein mensch im
badeanzug
ich weiß nicht welcher mechanismus sie
dazu bringt sich zu ändern aber
vielleicht ist es die freiheit die
tatsache dass sie nicht im büro sind in
ihrer normalen rolle
dass sie sich gehen lassen können
ich habe es selbst erlebt dass es im
schwimmbad wie im kindergarten zugeht
wegen all der dinge die dort passieren
man bräuchte ein buch um das alles zu
erzählen
es geht nicht nur um das fehlen der
richtigen kleidung
höflich ist in jemen ist kein gegenstand
der touristen ausrüster mit den
touristen
[Musik]
man braucht viel geduld um unsere arbeit
zu machen es ist etwas das mir egal
antun sonst würden wir es ja nicht
machen wir haben es jeden tag mit ganz
anderen menschen zu tun mit anderen
kulturen verhaltensweisen und
empfindlichkeiten niemand will schlecht
über seine kunden reden aber es gibt
doch einige anekdoten
manche kunden nutzen die bewertungen um
leistungen zu bekommen die sie sonst
nicht bekommen würden
ich erinnere mich an einen kunden der
mir sagte er würde eine schlechte
bewertung schreiben wenn er für das
parken bezahlen muss
und manchmal gibt es sogar diebstahl
aschenbecher der löffel der bademantel
und wurde sogar schon ein gemälde und
ein fernseher gestohlen das ist in
zürich passiert wo ich früher gearbeitet
habe von einer person mit jackett und
krawatte nicht ein armer mensch der
nicht zahlen kann sondern in einem
luxushotel
diese person bad in porto um eine box
brief an der rezeption an und sagte
kommen sie in zehn minuten hoch ich muss
etwas zu meinem auto bringen er hatte
den fernseher in die kiste gepackt gab
dem portier 10 franken trinkgeld kommt
ging mit dem fernseher weg
[Musik]
glücklicherweise sind das einzelfälle
lästiger ist die seite des
massentourismus die den eindruck erweckt
der tourist sei wichtiger als der
einwohner liegt liester importanteil
resident würden sie mir bitte ein glas
weißwein geben wie bitte würden sie mir
bitte ein glas weißwein geben nein ein
glas weißwein
ja wie viele wander du auch
der tourismus im tessin ist schon
bekannt ich erinnere mich an die 70er
anfang der 80er jahre mit marco solari
als direktor des tessiner
tourismusverbandes als der versuch tat
ascona deutschsprachig zu machen weil in
ascona alles nur auf deutsch geschrieben
war
wenn man dagegen bisher der linie
wir haben unser papier
[Musik]
es ist eine situation an die sich ältere
menschen gut erinnern gerade dank einer
versteckten kamera für die wochen
sendung reporter im jahr 1976
den ober tourism gab es schon lange
vorher aber eher woanders die touristen
kamen dann die strände der küste
in diesen gegenden gab es nicht so viele
einwohner das land weil er der rallye
portugal so konnten sie sich ausbreiten
jetzt sprechen wir von robert riss im
waller in den städten stattfindet der
wochenendurlaub in der stadt hat enorm
zugenommen und der schlüssel zu so einem
kurzurlaub ist dass die touristen zu
ihnen nach hause kommen sie sind nicht
nur in ihrer stadt sondern auch in ihrer
wohnung sie sind überall und der abstand
zwischen einheimischen und touristen
reicht nicht aus die einheimische
bevölkerung hat keinen raum wo sie
hingehen und sagen kann das ist meins
[Musik]
der massentourismus begann im juli 1841
in leicester einer nordenglischen stadt
der nordmilch
thomas cook eine baptistische pfarrer
war besorgt über den übermäßigen
alkoholkonsum der arbeiter seiner stadt
um sie abzulenken organisierte er
sonntagsausflüge mit dem zug 11 meilen
entfernte laufen die distanz mehr als
500 menschen nahmen daran teil es war
die erste einer unendlichen reihe von
organisierten reisen die dampflokomotive
zwischen den beiden städten gibt es
immer noch die strecke ist praktisch
dieselbe aber heute treffen wir
professor servia von der university of
st er forscht an strategien für den
umgang mit dem phänomen dass durch diese
eisenbahn entstanden war
[Musik]
es gibt viele lösungen wenn der
politische wille vorhanden ist es gibt
einige große unternehmen die sehr
schnell wachsen das sind online
reisebüros die kein persönliches
interesse an einer bestimmten stadt
haben
sie haben nur ein kommerzielles
interesse das führt zu einem
preisanstieg für die bewohner die dann
rausgeschmissen werden weil sie keinen
preiswerten wohnraum befinden
wir sind im gotischen viertel von
barcelona im zentrum und hier sind wir
an der plaza medina sally
das ist ein sehr interessanter platz
aber wirklich sehr traurig dies ist ein
platz der vor 30 jahren noch voller
leben war um diesen platz herum gab es
nur wohnungen
und jetzt wohnt hier niemand mehr wir
haben hotels
luxus hotels luxus wohnungen
das ist nicht das niveau der menschen
die ihr leben
hier ist eine piazza auf der kein leben
mehr stattfindet weil alle leute die
hier vorbeikommen vier tage lang bleiben
um die stadt zu sehen und dann wieder
verschwinden
es ist ein hit and run tourismus der mit
rollkoffern über deine füße über die
einwohner und das wirtschaftliche
gleichgewicht wenn mal wurde der billige
massentourismus mit dem tausende von
menschen in scharen von einem ort zum
anderen der stadt getrieben werden die
verursacht ein ungutes gefühl und wenn
sie erschöpft sind sitzen sie auf den
denkmälern und essen auf der straße
diejenigen die sie kritisieren wissen
nicht dass sie keine große wahl haben
einer damit wenig geld kommt bringt ein
sandwich mit und setzt sich auf den
markusplatz um es zu essen du sagst das
können sie nicht machen ihr müsst sagen
das geht hier nicht aber da drüben gibt
es schöne gärten wo man einen großen
tisch haben kann für einen euro kann man
sich da hinsetzen und hat studenten die
aufräumen das ist zivilisiertes
verhalten man zeigt den besuchern die
kommen seine zivilisation
stattdessen sieht man nur strände
furchtbare strände an denen sie zog aus
taiwan verkaufen das ist unsere eigene
schuld die schulter statt
[Musik]
arrigo cipriani bezeichnet sich in einem
seiner bücher als gefangenen in einem
raum das ist sein restaurant das
berühmte harry's bar ein muss für alle
heute und in der vergangenheit in
italien und im ausland in italien
als venezianer und weltbürger wünscht
sich cipriani seine stadt könnte besser
mit dem phänomen der überfüllung durch
touristen umgehen
[Musik]
der rialto markt war der schönste
supermarkt der welt jetzt ist er es
nicht mehr er ist eine ansammlung von
ständen geworden die alles verkaufen
vorher waren die märkte immer das herz
der stadt
[Musik]
auch sind die märkte die als typisch
gelten beliebte orte für touristen die
das authentische sucht riester in die
kita aber durch die große anzahl an
ständen zerstören die touristen das
wonach sie suchen
[Musik]
die preise steigen anstelle der
grundbedürfnisse werden an den ständen
zu minis verkauft und dann gehen die
bewohner weg um dieses problem zu
vermeiden will die stadt barcelona jetzt
den touristen den zutritt zum
lebensmittelmarkt auf den ramblas
verbieten
[Musik]
früher konnten wir hier einkaufen aber
jetzt ist es schwer überhaupt rein zu
kommen ich wohne dort am ende der
ramblas und viele leute gehen auf den
santa catarina markt
ich gehe auch auf den anderen läden weil
es hier schwierig erst überhaupt rein zu
kommen
es sind immer viele touristen da ja
die marktleute kann am tourismus
verdienen
aber an markt sollte auch für die
menschen in der nachbarschaft seien
nicht nur für touristen
sie sollten sich mehr um die anwohner
können nicht nur um die touristen
man muss versuchen alle glücklich
finden sie dass sich zu viele touristen
ist
das glaube ich nicht das einzige was man
tun könnte wäre ein bisschen tourismus
zuzulassen
wir wollen keinen massentourismus aber
guten tourismusjahr
ist es schwer hier einzukaufen es sind
sehr viele leute hier den kennedys stört
sie das
ja manchmal aber es macht es lebendiger
sicher wir beschweren uns viel aber es
gibt leben
für die älteren menschen die auf den
bänken der ramblas sitzen und sich
unterhalten wie sie es früher vor ihren
häusern getan haben sind die touristen
kein problem danke steve glauben sie
dass es zu viele touristen geben
nein ich mag dass die menschen sind sehr
unterschiedlich manche mögen es andere
nicht manche stören sich an alle aber
ich nicht
ist es als würde man sie vom balkon aus
beobachten
hier kann man alles sehen
im sommer sieht man leute herum laufen
fast nackig und andere mit mänteln
es gibt so ziemlich alles
aber auch für diejenigen die sich nicht
an den touristen stören sondern von
ihnen leben wird es langsam beunruhigen
ich glaube dass wir alle herausfinden
müssen wo die grenze ist denn wenn ich
den tourismus nur für geld nutze bis ich
sterbe aber
in gewisser weise bringe ich meine
wirtschaft um gehen wenn es am ende
weniger touristen gibt weil der ort
nicht mehr so interessant ist
das was die leute sehen wollen zerstört
das ist auch für die touristen
weg ist sagt ich will sehen wie die
menschen hier leben nicht wie die
touristen ihr leben für künstlich zu
hause bleiben
wenn ich an einen ort fahre möchte ich
wirklich etwas über den ort erfahren
in boston
ja
einer weile
[Musik]
ein dilemma für das professor von
versucht eine lösung zu finden die multi
chip als berater für viele städte auch
für barcelona
[Musik]
barcelona habe ich vorgeschlagen die art
des marketings zu ändern
die weniger geld in das marketing und
mehr geld in das management des
reiseziels zu investieren sie müssen
aufhören es zum objekt des wachstums zu
machen und es als synonym für erfolg
sehen war erfolg besteht darin dass man
in der lage ist touristen anzuziehen die
das wohlbefinden der einwohner steigern
und die negativen auswirkungen auf die
umwelt in der stadt verringern das
bedeutet zum beispiel dem hit and run
tourismus entgegen zu wirken die
konzentration an denselben orten zu
vermeiden und eine gewisse integration
mit der ansässigen bevölkerung zu
fördern
das ist mehr oder weniger das was die
stadt barcelona versucht darin besteht
im wesentlichen das tourismusmanagement
nicht den status quo die aktuelle
situation des tourismus in der stadt in
frage zu stellen sondern zu versuchen
ihn besser zu managen wenn zum beispiel
die busse voll sind setzt man mehr busse
ein an dem tag an dem es mehr busse auf
der straße gibt werden sie mehr
straßenbaum
oder man macht einfach weiter ohne die
situation in frage zu stellen
als versammlung des viertels haben wir
vorgeschlagen die bedeutung des
tourismus für die wirtschaft der stadt
zu verringern
damit sie nicht so einem tourismus
monopol wird
was wir praktisch sind
[Musik]
für die berühmtesten touristischen orte
ist es schwierig den vorzügen des
tourismus und seine einnahmen zu
widerstehen in venedig war das gebiet um
das achte mal früher sehr bevölkert dort
lebten hunderte von arbeitern in china
ja die laboratorien als was rational
geschlossen wurde und die arbeitsplätze
verschwanden wird dieses gebiet neben
der biennale heute nach und nach zur
beute derer die es zu einem neuen
touristenviertel machen wollen die
touristiker
annaburg auto ist in der schweiz
aufgewachsen und lebt seit langem in
venedig tun sie kennt dieses viertel
sehr gut
früher gab es dort einen obst- und
gemüseladen jetzt ist er geschlossen und
ein lagerhaus
oben gibt es nur noch touristen
wohnungen
hier wohl niemandem mehr
ihr war ein tischler drin
jetzt ist es auch ein lagerhaus in
diesem hof gibt es nur noch touristen
wohnung
alles wurde in wohnungen für besucher
umgewandelt
dies hier ist der einzige
lebensmittelladen der auf der insel san
marino noch existiert
und wie läuft das geschäft hier in der
letzten zeit
nun ich würde sagen in letzter zeit
wegen der fehlenden bevölkerung nicht
sehr gut
[Musik]
was soll ich sagen sagen wir mal so
früher wurde der mangel an einwohnern
durch die touristen aufgefangen
jetzt ist der tourismus so massiv dass
selbst das nicht mehr ausreicht um die
kosten zu decken
es gibt kein gewerbe mehr in der stadt
manchmal kommt ein tourist und fragt
mich nach irgendwas und ich muss ihnen
sagen er so noch mehr treffen um es zu
kaufen weil wir es hier nicht mehr haben
wenn es zu diesen ausfällen kommen
verlieren wir das gewerbe das profil
verlieren alles die traditionen alles
und das ist vorbei
auf der anderen seite der stadt an der
fundamente della misericordia ist die
lage ähnlich
klara 10 ads studenten der stadt
anthropologie und untersucht die
veränderungen wie in venedig seit dem
ende des krieges stattgefunden haben
das hier ist das ausgeführte von venedig
geworden mit einer unglaublichen
konzentration von bars die andere
aktivitäten verdrängen
das liegt daran dass die mieten die die
bars in venedig zahlen können viel höher
sind als die die ein anderes normales
geschäft zahlen kann
ein allgemeiner anstieg sei die
abwanderung der bevölkerung beschleunigt
hat
die stadt im wasser die inselstadt hat
seit den 50er jahren mehr als zwei
drittel ihrer einwohner verloren
heute gibt es nur noch 54 1000 einwohner
also eine sehr kleine bevölkerung das
bedeutet dass sich die
wirtschaftsstruktur der stadt stark
verändert hat
ich kann eh lasogga und der tourismus
allmählich zur wichtigsten aktivitäts
und heute fast so ausschließlichen
aktivität geworden ist
[Musik]
diese veränderungen kamen in den letzten
jahren durch das unnatürliche und
exponentielle wachstum des tourismus
der tourismus ist kein spontanes
phänomen er ist ein produziertes
phänomen dass ursachen und bedingungen
hat er ist nicht ewig denn er beruht auf
bestimmten historischen bedingungen wie
zb den niedrigen treibstoffkosten die
niedrigen transportkosten in den
bezahlten urlaub alles dinge die wir
heute als selbstverständlich ansehen
aber wer weiß ob es diese dinge morgen
noch geben wird
was uns angst macht ist das die struktur
der venezianischen gesellschaft wenn sie
einmal zerstört ist nur schwer wieder
herzustellen sein wird die venezianer
mit denen ich gesprochen habe sehen
keine zukunft sie sehen ein prozess der
tendenziell nur noch schlimmer wird und
einige sagen ich hoffe dass ich dann
nicht mehr da sein werde ich hoffe dass
ich dann schon tot bin
[Musik]
für die
naja
[Musik]
die venezianer irren sich die venezianer
waren immer offen für die welt und jetzt
ist er ein kleiner provinzler geworden
das tut den venezianern wie
auch den touristen
ich würde es verstehen wenn es eine
invasionsarmee wäre aber es ist keine
invasion
ich sehe dass sie auf den boten den
wampe red die unhöflichkeit sich
schubsen die leute das ist es was die
venezianer die geblieben sind tun das
ist falsch wir erwecken den eindruck
einer toten statt
arrigo cipriani mit seinem ehrwürdigen
86 jahren hat eine optimistischere sicht
auf die zukunft venedig
venedig hat viele geschichten erlebt
viele plagen vor der pest gab es hier
250.000 menschen nach der pest nur noch
50.000 und die stadt wurde immer wieder
aufgebaut oder
also ich halte das für eine
vorübergehende phase einen moment in der
historischen epoche
die elbe und die flut der geschichte
lehren uns dass auch schönheit nicht
immer alle veränderungen überlebt hat
sie so intakt wie möglich zu erhalten
ist die aufgabe jeder generation
[Musik]